with me now i work in pension secretary
to raise coffee who is backing liz truss
in the leadership competition talk about
that in just a second just want to talk
though about the urgent question
yesterday after prime minister's
questions our ambulance service is on
high alert there was an urgent question
from labour there was no secretary of
state available to answer that are we
running a zombie government at the
moment
well actually within um just tackling
the issue of ambulances first i get that
as a constituency mp i've been
working on this actually for a decade
and seeing how the different
organizations and strategies about how
we're trying to improve elements for
patients it's our local nhs that runs uh
this uh the nhs east of england but
across the country i know there's been
particular pressure with handoffs
from ambulances into hospitals and it's
those sorts of elements where we really
need the ambulance trust to get a grip
working with the hospitals so we can get
ambulances back out on the road for
patients but nevertheless i appreciate
there was an urgent question yesterday
it's actually westminster practice that
normally it isn't the secretary of state
that responds to urgent questions but
other other ministers
but importantly it's um here today as
well because i've stayed imposed in
order to make sure that we can get out
the cost of living payment today which
we are doing and over 1.6 million
households will be receiving 326 pounds
in their bank account today to help them
with the cost of living but if there's a
cobra meeting i'm guessing that the
government thinks that there is a big
issue so you would have thought the
health secretary could take time out of
his busy schedule to talk to the public
via tv cameras
well i i don't know the arrangement for
the department of health i know i'm
responsible for your acceptance it's a
problem a big problem i don't know
because i don't know what happened
yesterday the ambulance services are on
high alert so well i understand that and
as i've explained as a constituency mp
uh my own ambulance trust has been rated
inadequate uh i'm pleased to see that
locally they finally listened to mp
feedback and in my not responsible for
the weather in my own ambulance trust
i'm very conscious of the need to
operate at a slightly lower and we're
doing that by county but i think it's
because of the impact of high weather
sorry very hot weather that the risk to
people particularly elderly has gone up
and therefore it's appropriate that we
do take
substantial action to make sure that
ambulance trusts are on high alert and
prioritize appropriately what are you
doing as a government
well as a government i'm just conscious
that i am
as we've said we're trying to make sure
ambulance trusts on high alert and
prioritizing but also the am the
hospitals to be able to unload patients
uh to take them into their care as
quickly as possible across purposes
something different to you to what it
means to the ambulance service when
they're on high alert that means that
they're in trouble
well as i've pointed out one of the
challenges that we've been seeing with
waiting times for patients to get an
ambulance has risen significantly that's
my understanding why ministers have been
stepping in to try and get that
prioritization but also with the hot
weather we know that's a bigger risk
particularly for elderly so it is about
making sure the nhs whether for the
patients is working optimal
at full opt sorry
full rate to make sure that they can try
and help patients but as i say i'm the
secretary of state for work and pensions
i know that my officials have been
working relentlessly since we had the
announcement of the extra support for
over eight million households and i'm
really pleased that those payments are
landing today and i'm anticipating all
the payments that we will be making will
be done by the end of july okay um why
are you supporting supporting liz trust
she's got a lot of work to do hasn't she
liz trust is a credible
cabinet minister with extended service
and a variety of departments uh most
recently of course being foreign
secretary and i think she's worked
exceptionally well in representing our
country around the world but
particularly on ukraine she's the lady
that finally she was the one that got
nazanin back did the negotiations but
also her work on trade deals shows that
she can do those negotiations around the
world i think that uh clearly she has
going to be saying in a speech later
today some more of her plans but i've
always been impressed by her ever since
i've got into parliament and i think
that she is also known for getting a
grip focusing on delivery and i also
believe that is one of the most critical
things that we will be doing in the next
two years uh up until the next election
okay liz is the one okay so what would
you say to the supporters of um kemi
baranok and swala bravaman because you
are going to need those votes and more
in order for it to get over the line why
should they come to you rather than stay
with those candidates
well
um okay i'm very conscious that this uh
leadership contest is very intensive and
there's a lot of personal emotions that
people go through they put their
allegiance to one candidate or another
and when their candidate doesn't do as
well as perhaps they would like it can
take a little bit of time for that to
absorb the reason why i think supporters
of suella and kemi should come and join
liz is because
a lot of their policies are in the very
similar direction about having a free
economy about making sure that we stand
up for the united kingdom be proud of
our country
and indeed having that more
focus on aspects of delivery but a
different approach slightly on how we
tackle economic issues including
she says that she's open to leaving the
european convention of human rights uh
rhys mark who's also supporting her even
he wouldn't go that far what do you
think well in terms of um one
undoubtedly in terms of the echr the
european convention on human rights
i think it's fair to say most
politicians believe there's been mission
creep i would suggest and it would have
been a surprise to the british public
to hear uh one morning that a european
court had blocked um in effect that the
plane going to rwanda recognizing our
latest immigration policy uh but i think
at a meeting the other night uh all the
candidates i'm aware of that were
there whether that would think was rishi
as it was reported on one of those uh um
blogs called playbook uh they all
indicated that uh they would rather get
reform and that is liz's position uh in
order to reform the nchr
and also to do the bill of rights and
others did say uh that uh if
if necessary uh they would be up for uh
for that as well i think that's you
ducking my question so i'm gonna come
back to it do you think that we should
leave the european convention of human
rights i think we need to reform uh
where we are that's what we're doing
well we're doing that with the bill of
rights
and should we leave the european
convention well theresa may
said uh what do you think theresa may
said during the eu referendum
uh that she would rather leave the echr
than leave the european union so i think
it indicates this is a broad view across
a lot of theresa may i'm asking you well
i'm not the person running for
leadership i'm here but you have a view
jury smoke's not running for leadership
but he has a view i mean some would say
he's slightly right of attila but he
still wouldn't leave the european court
of human convention what i am in favor
of is about reforming of the you you're
not sure why you weren't supported
uh and because i am uh here to uh
represent the government in terms of our
cost of living
at the moment you're asking me questions
about the views of a variety of
leadership candidates in my view but i'm
i'm i'm you're entitled to have your own
view okay i've said very clearly it's
important that we get the reform and
avoid the mission creep and that's what
we will be doing through the bill of
rights it's a bit like next week
recognizing the
different legislation that we have we're
prioritizing northern ireland protocol
and the reason why that is is because we
want to make sure that we have the
appropriate uh powers to make changes if
necessary so governments will like to
act in different ways to make sure that
they have the levers they need to uh
deploy as appropriate uh in the future
in terms of negotiations with other i'll
just share with my views and we'll move
on only russia and belarus are not
members of the or yeah not members of
the european convention on human rights
we'll we'll park that there and they can
make up their own minds um talk to me
about suggestions of dirty tricks nadine
doris says there are dirty tricks and
rishi sunak the former chancellor who's
lending votes left right and center to
keep your candidate out my main focus is
on getting liz trust into the final two
of the mps that's my choice yeah and
that's what i will continue to do i'm
not going to get into other campaigns
okay but
so nadine doris misspoke
uh i i don't know i'm not saying nadine
misspoke at all all i'm saying is i'm
focused on liz truss and that's what
matters to me getting her in the final
two okay uh what do you think about
rashid not being a socialist
in terms of i'm conscious that other
people will come to their own
conclusions
i've been working with rishi clearly
there are some slightly different uh
views on what we should have done on
where various levies and similar
but with collective agreement and
government uh of course people will uh
have been voting for that in the past
but nevertheless this is now leadership
contest and liz will be setting out her
views in her speech lately okay how
surprised are you that penny morden's
doing as well as she is
i think we've got a great range of
talent in our conservative party and in
our conservative government
and you know i know that penny is an
assiduous person but i am supporting
this trust because i think liz has the
full package in terms of experience
grippiness in terms of delivery and
that's why i'll be supporting her um
it's fascinating that she
um is apparently more brexiteering than
nadine doris and
uh jacob reese mark together they made
that comment didn't they when they were
outside number 10 downing street the
other day and i'm sure she voted remain
well i think um uh i think she did vote
remain however so the point is that
we're democrats
and in terms of wants a decision to be
made by the british people
that's respected
and i think you have to judge people
by how they have responded since
the referendum
liz certainly has been out there
selling the uk around the world for both
exports and inward investment she really
has been delivering on making the
benefits of brexit come to life more
perhaps than any other cabinet minister
that i've seen yeah but she was on her
way to indonesia to do that as well
wasn't she but she soon got back on the
plane as soon as she heard that boris
johnson had resigned how long do you
think she's been
quietly planning to be prime minister
um i know uh that uh liz has been
absolutely focused on her job and has
been in terms of supporting the prime
minister because it was important to
continue disability government it was
right that liz went to bali to the g20
she didn't turn any plane around she
went there to do what she needed to do
including making sure that she signed
the agreement so that sweden and finland
could have the fast-track scheme to join
nato net this mechanism has never been
deployed before that's how
important making sure that the interests
of the united kingdom in a global
britain
i thought that had already been done
before she went to indonesia
this was important part of her trip in
g20 was to make sure that those
agreements were absolutely signed so
this is why liz will always put country
first
rather than that modern politics and the
best interests of our nation and i'm
pleased that she did that i know
there'll be other people thinking why
didn't she just turn the plane around
she and come back she didn't she did
what was necessary in order to be the
excellent foreign secretary she's been
and that shows the kind of leadership
that she will i believe lead our country
into just before i let you go um she's
been described as 21st century
margaret thatcher now that is very
appealing to the grassroots of the
conservative party perhaps less so to
the wider public and she will have to
face an election within two years or two
years at the very farthest distance um
how appealing will that be to the wider
public
liz trust is my friend liz trust is liz
truss she doesn't need to be a copycat
of anybody else she is her own person
you know a lady that went to school in
paisley in scotland uh then then onto a
comprehensive in leeds and she's a lady
who has really shown that with hard work
real focus and her experiences in
schools is why she's so passionate about
improving education standards and wants
to make sure that the four corners of
the united kingdom stay as the united
kingdom but also that we all lift in
terms of prosperity so i'm absolutely
committed i'm actually convinced that
she will continue to be able to deliver
the mission of levelling up while also
making sure uh that we get a grip of all
the issues that we're facing right now
and lead us into victory in the next
generation it's not helpful to compare
it and margaret thatcher then i would
say that she is liz trusts other people
can make their judgments but i think
she's a fantastic lady and i think she
should be the next prime minister we'll
see very soon won't we it's great to
talk to you thanks so much for joining
us thank you